for you like uh I know doing your tour
like is a big deal because I feel like
you're kind of doing something that a
lot of La artists have had trouble doing
yeah and that's like doing like a
national tour yeah you know and I think
like a lot of that is just the result of
like [__] the last 15 projects straight
of just you know building your monthly
listeners and and I think like uh
I've noticed like that for you because I
think we always look at a lot of
quote-unquote La rappers as having a
certain ceiling but I do feel like
you've done a good job of like starting
to break out of what that ceiling looks
like for sure
for sure like my goal my goal in the
culture and my contribution is to
is to bring something new to LA and when
I say newest you know
our culture and the way we operate out
here is like to chill hang and bang [__]
and it also spill over into the hustle
so a lot of people do the minimum and
expect the maximum and uh you know
another one of my things with branding
is perception and making it impossible
possible and seeing you know like where
other people don't see and you know it
is a market for us on the term road but
you got to step out and build that [__]
up so my goal is to you know just show
[__] that's coming up after me
that yeah you could make millions
as a West Coast artist doing West Coast
[__] we got to just go open up these
markets that [__] with us so you know
you may go do a show
um I didn't have shows that I did like
when I did my very first tour bro that
[__] was it was humbling first of all
right but it didn't make me want to quit
it's like when I first got my first dope
sack like I had a quarter piece and then
it took me forever to sell that [__] you
know what I'm saying but I kept going so
I didn't have shows where it's [__]
20 people there right you know I mean in
a 500 cap room right and I rocked it
like it was you know sold out yeah but
that [__] um
that should make a lot of people run and
hide from it because you putting
yourself out there and you know you
creating this image of I'm already on
and I got all this [__] so the steps
that you got to take a lot of people put
their mind
to where this image is fake it till you
make it already got it so when it's time
to do this [__] it's like it don't mess
it don't mess with your brand so you
can't really grow but my whole thing is
to just you know let [__] know
what is money and touring we do gotta
market and like you could make M's like
independent and you don't need to
[__] go to a label and have this
whole fake [__] going on and hope that
you hit the lotto right because that's
really what it is you gotta if you're
gonna sign to a major you kind of got to
hit the lotto because you kind of need a
hit record to happen for sure
and even then
maybe you don't recoup and then and
you're F you're never really gonna
recoup because it's kind of set up it's
set up to never recoup look the average
artist
90 of [__] deals is like a royalty
deal even [__] that say they got JVS
this [__] be [__] fluff for a
headline so it's like a uh on average
it's a 85-15 type [__] or 12 royalty
right but what they don't tell you is
that when they spend a million on you
and you recoup you could make five
million but or let's just let's break it
down even smaller they spent a hundred
thousand on you and you make 200 000.
you really only recoup thirty thousand
dollars right because you're only
recouping yeah it's it's pretty much
for every dollar that so let's say you
have a ten percent royalty deal right
just that's an even number so
essentially
every ten dollars that comes in out of a
hundred goes towards paying your balance
off right the rest of it they just put
it it just got free so it's like you're
not recouped but we made a shitload of
money that's right so for you to really
recoup off that hundred your music needs
to make a million if you're on a 10 rate
exactly and that's how you recoup and
then you start getting a royal teacher
how much is how much streams you really
need to do to make a million dollars off
of a record or an album it's it's a
serious amount exactly and it's like
that's why you know people complain
about these deals and the deal don't get
restructured what they do is they don't
hesitate to give you more money because
it's like it's a great deal for them
it's a great business [__] yeah
exactly it's not like they didn't make
no money
you didn't you just didn't recoup but we
made money so oh man you got a problem
we love you we want to here's another
million dollars drop an album yeah here
goes it because we made a shitload of
money already
that should be happening with so many
artists that I know where they'll
complain but then they'll they'll take
the advance yeah because it's like all
right take the events because what they
complaining about they need money okay
cool here's money here goes some money
all right you better tour yeah we just
put a Band-Aid over some [__] that needs
Staples and stitches and now you got
more money to recoup you've done you've
dug your whole deeper with the label but
that there is something that
people I think have a uh
so if you aren't recouped it's not so I
think normal people think that when they
hear that that if you're not recouped
that you didn't make money no that you
are like in debt to the label right like
personal right like no like if the label
gives you a million dollars
and your music only makes a hundred
thousand dollars
now you might not be recruit through
your deal right but it's not like you're
moving around with a [__] nine
hundred thousand dollar debt over your
head right the label yeah because I
gonna write if they let that if they let
you go They're gonna write you off like
with with rock man it's a tax write-off
yeah we're Roc Nation they let me go and
it's like I think I'll [__] owed them
like eight hundred thousand did you see
what little Russell said that like Roc
Nation offered him like a really bad
deal
uh yeah yeah I saw that interview yeah
was that how was your deal no my
situation went nothing like that but you
know at the end of the day this is
business like in business people are
gonna do and get over with what they can
I'm saying and it's up to you to catch
up with it like
um
even with lawyers and [__] like these
lawyers are slick as a [__] and
a lot of times they all like like they
kind of they work together yeah and like
you got to kind of really find your own
like entertainment lawyer that's kind of
like maybe not living in La for sure
like because or somebody that's fresh
out of college that's like somebody with
you you know right because they will try
to they will try to sneak [__] in like I
know how the situation to where
I worked out a deal and this
[__] telling me all right
everything is great I don't like this I
don't like this I'm gonna tell them this
but didn't tell me that he slept in
I need five percent out of this deal in
the contract you tell me everything else
but forget to and a lot of people get
[__] like that but I'll be on top of
everything so because it's like I could
just pay you for your hourly fee um
yeah but it's like a [__]
they'll Court you
highest love bro I'm here for you let
you know everything and then still sneak
in some [__] under your nose like all
this [__] go on you know I mean but you
can't get mad at it it's the games I
think that I see well I noticed that too
with a lot of managers you know on top
of it managers
shitty managers will back though you
they'll force their artists into a
shitty record deal because they don't
got to recoup off the advance they get
their percentage scot-free yeah I need
to pay those rent so they're getting
their bread meanwhile you're locked into
a shitty deal and you're not gonna
recoup and it's like what the manager
got paid the lawyer got paid right yeah
I mean I see that [__] happening all the
time or else like like some of my homies
are like they're [__] management will
like be pushing them to sign like shitty
deals and I'm like bro because I want
it's a red flag and managers like that
that's how a lot of managers think
I'm the coach I outlive the artist I'm
gonna have 30 more of you like the
[__] I didn't heard somebody
say I'm not gonna say who but close to
him [__] average artist lifestyle
lifespan is five years but that's really
not the case no more because rapping
turned into rock and roll right too
short damn near 60 and he's still the
[__] yeah he's almost 60 yes he like 55
56 how old is sugar-free sugar-free is
around the same thing 53 54 but it's
like rapping and turned into rock and
roll so it's it's no age limit but like
people
um
a bad management to tell you [__] like
that and then put this
idea in your head that you gotta rush
into these [__] up situations because
you only got a window you know what I
mean but if you're a brand you're gonna
be here forever rappers do got a [__]
expiration date but Brands don't right
uh are you pretty much self-managed now
or do you have management yeah because I
feel like it you could kind of you you
know you're one of the few artists I
feel like probably don't need a manager
you have good people around you you got
a great price yeah yeah yeah yeah Empire
like Gentry yeah Gentry my project
manager you know what I'm saying and
he's like
he's definitely one of the best like
this doing some groundbreaking I think
Gentry gonna be one of the people that
like changed the game in the future but
you know he assists me but as far as uh
management man I you know I do I'm a
mastermind like you know not to toot my
own horn but like I'm a hustler so it's
like I know that
the game is like it's really only 10 in
the music it's 90 of how you position
yourself how you set up your brand and
how you do all this and I was just
telling somebody the other day like
man I only need to do [__] 15 percent
of what a major artist gotta do and I'm
getting the same money or more and I
probably do what I want and I feel like
I could like I feel great you know what
I'm saying I felt like I honestly felt
like
like music turned into a job when I
signed yeah I mean and it just turned
into pressure because the the lights in
it and the perception of this [__] oh he
would Rock Nation and just like that
[__] [__] up a gang of relationships
with me because [__] is next to
me but not paying attention to what's
really going on just like the look of
[__] you know what I'm saying so like
independent is where it's at man like
people will sign for the wrong reasons
like you said it's the look it's the
like now I'm on here I get to go to the
brunch or I you know it's like that [__]
is great and like shout out to that you
know but like
I don't think I think that your your
life is way more important than that
yeah your peace of mind your freedom
your flexibility all these things that
freedom is everything because I wanted
to quit when I said I was retiring I
really felt like that like [__] this I
know
I'm a cold [__] I could go make
millions anywhere I'm a hustler so it's
like like music had me jaded for a
minute and it like just being
independent I told gazi man I said bro
like
bro you gave me Freedom bro like
I respect you and lay you for that you
know what I'm saying so like you know
you got me